hi I'm Erik Bosse and Netflix this new
Syfy series altered carbon is position
to be the new high concept action
mystery series I hope we all go nutty
about at least until Westbrook comes
back in three shadows or lines I'm gonna
explain what altered carbon is the book
it's adapted from and how with
influences like Blade Runner and the
matrix it could be the thrilling
thoughtful sci-fi mystery that you have
to watch to stay relevant because it a
minute that's what this is all about
you're afraid of missing out wormholes
great okay altered carbon was a 2002
sci-fi novel by Richard Morgan about a
future where human consciousnesses can
be transferred to new bodies after they
die these new bodies are called sleeves
their whole consciousnesses and memories
up until that point when they died are
stored in stacks that are digitally
inserted into the new replacement bodies
now most people in the society can only
afford to Reese lead once at the end of
their lives and then after that
replacement sleeve grows old they decide
not to do it again but the super super
wealthy one percenters can Reese leave
continuously living on for hundreds of
years if they want to now these are
called meths a reference to the biblical
figure Methuselah who according to
Scripture lived the longest to the age
of 969 but the story of altered carbon
is a mystery the richest man on earth a
meth named Lorenz Bancroft who Reese
leaves every 48 hours was murdered and
Reese leaves this time with no memory of
the past two days so he wants to know
who killed him and why so we hire
someone to investigate this mystery
enter our hero Takeshi Kovich played by
Joel Kinnaman from Suicide Squad
Kovach was an end boy previously a super
soldier designed with neural muscle
memory and heightened senses to engage
in combat on other planets by the way in
this story that was the whole origin of
the sleeve technology humans developed
Lightspeed interstellar travel and
needed a way to transport
consciousnesses into new host bodies
across the galaxy that could handle each
of these new environments in Kovach's
case he's haunted by this military past
in the book it was a nasty battle on
another planet where envoy's were
infected with a lethal virus but in the
show it looks like that pass will
involve Kovach flipping sides to join a
rebel leader but now 250 years later
this super soldier has been relieved
into the body of Elias Ryker
a cop in base
a future version of San Francisco this
Detective noir style mystery introduces
him to Lawrence bancroft's femme fatale
wife Miriam and Kristen Ortega a base
city cop who is the former partner and
lover of kodachi's host body
now the novel altered carbon 1 the
philip k dick award for best novel in
2003 which makes sense because this
series has dicks DNA all over it Frazee
philip k dick of course wrote Blade
Runner which Ridley Scott adapted into
the 1982 film it inspired pretty much
every dystopian sci-fi that came since
including last year's unappreciated
sequel Blade Runner 2049 from a
production design standpoint altered
carbon is definitely standing on Blade
Runner cyberpunk shoulders Kovach is a
gruff detective in a long coat an
upturned collar deeply haunted by his
past as he struggles in an unnatural
body much like Harrison Ford's Deckard
the grimy setting the bass city is
covered in neon screen high-rises and
flying cars much like blade runner's
future Los Angeles mostly altered carbon
seems to be following blade runners lead
and asking those big questions about
humanity's relationship with technology
when the human soul no longer has to be
linked with a human body is humanity
really that exceptional at that point
like a technology allows us to keep
living forever that would make the human
race masters of death even to some
pretty fascinating side effects for
example major supply to the book centers
around how Catholics refused to Reese
leave after death believing Souls should
go to heaven that makes them targets for
murder since their consciousnesses
wouldn't be left behind as witnesses the
part of the book is a whole legal
attempt to circumvent that so that
Catholic murder victims can testify
societal consequences like these are
what define great science fiction and
philip k dick Bladerunner was really one
of the first to get us to apply that if
this then what else mindset to the genre
and if you'd like to blade runner' in
the recent sequel but you wish there was
just a bit more forward moving plot and
action to keep you invested in these
deeper themes ultra carbon might be
exactly what you're looking for now I
won't say much about this upcoming
season but the mystery is extremely
narrative ly dense with lots of
interweaving plot threads and well
choreographed action they explore the
idea of sleeves from several interesting
angles including one episode showing an
All Hallows holiday where people Reese
leave as different identities kind of
like Halloween costumes the show might
actually remind you a lot of another
filled cave dick inspired
my story the matrix that film embraced
the dystopian aesthetic and tech
humanity themes of Blade Runner without
being an exact replica of it and so does
altered carbon like the matrix altered
carbons story charges forward with more
urgency and exciting stunt work there's
even a neo Morpheus type relationship
between Kovach's past in boy identity
played by Will Young Lee and the rebel
leader he joins up with well Crist
Falconer best name ever played by rene
elise Goldsberry aka Angelica Schuyler
from Hamilton the series was created by
a lady at Cal egregious a longtime TV
and film writer who worked on movies
like shutter island' and avatar and she
says something such a great creative
team for this series the first episode
out of the past was directed by Miguel
saponin who directed the best episodes
of Game of Thrones including battled the
Basterds hardhome in the winds of winter
and if this season of alter carbon is
successful Cal agreed is has plenty of
source material to pull from Richard
Morgan wrote to further sequel novels to
alter Carbon broken angels and woken
Furies so in case all the carbon does
end up becoming the next West world or
Game of Thrones or more likely a
commercially successful TV version of
Blade Runner I will be watching I just
can't miss out on things but now that
you're more caught up on alter carbon or
if you're watching this video after the
season is dropped on Netflix on February
2nd how would you say this show's
concept ranks among other philip k dick
inspired sci-fi from recent years like
Westworld or Blade Runner 2049 or the
great movie ex machina I already love
all those things so hopefully ultra
carbon will aim to be a unique and yet
another additional example of this kind
of high-concept sci-fi without trying to
improve upon or fix any of those already
great properties comment with your
thoughts down below or tweet me directly
at EA vaso we're probably new rock stars
on twitter at new rock starts like and
share this video and subscribe to new
rock stars for analysis of all kinds of
properties like this that you love like
Westworld Blade Runner and if you really
want to help this channel you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Kristina
Armstrong thanks for watching guys bye